the president will leave washington
tonight for a long-awaited and
politically delicate trip you could say
to the middle east mr biden will meet
with saudi arabia's crown prince who he
has bluntly criticized over the murder
of a journalist christina rafini is at
the white house with more on this story
christine as you know the president
taking a lot of heat for this trip so
why is he going
good morning gail that's right now first
the president will leave this evening
and start his trip in israel where he's
going to assure leaders there of
america's steadfast support then as you
mentioned he's headed to saudi a country
candidate biden once said should be
treated as a pariah after the 2018
killing and dismembering of washington
post journalist jamal khashoggi at the
hands of saudi mercenaries now with oil
prices still high due in part due to the
war in ukraine president biden will meet
with crown prince mohammed bin salman
the man u.s intelligence says approved
that murder now in a briefing yesterday
cbs asked national security adviser jake
sullivan if this trip means that
strategic interests like energy and
security are more important than human
rights sullivan said human rights are
also a strategic interest and america
can do multiple things at once now as
the president heads abroad there's a new
new york times and siena college poll
that shows that nearly two-thirds of
democratic voters surveyed think the
party should nominate another candidate
in 2024 that includes 94 percent of
voters under 30. the poll did show
however mr biden beating donald trump in
a hypothetical match-up but it's clear
democratic voters are looking for new
leadership
christina let me switch gears here
first lady jill biden is taking some
heat after people took offense at
comments she made at a latino rights
event in texas yesterday let's listen to
what she said
with the understanding that the
diversity of this community
as distinct as the bogotas of the bronx
as beautiful as the blossoms of miami
and as unique as the breakfast tacos
here in san antonio
all right obviously equating tacos with
the latino community is the issue that
many find incredibly offensive uh
christina what is the white house saying
about this
yeah no comment yet from the white house
this morning and those those comments
come
a day before mexican president lopez
obrador is here today to meet with mr
biden so the timing is especially uneasy
um you know look those remarks from the
first lady came as part of a prepared
speech praising the work of a well-known
activist the national association of
hispanic journalists condemned the
comments saying in part that latinos
should not be reduced to a stereotype
vlad
ah that is exactly right christina thank
you very much
we all agree with that absolutely
first lady's team probably huddling
today
because when you know joe biden that's
not who she is but it didn't come out
correctly